TAL SCULLY: Advice
for students, I
would say that the most
important thing for this class
is knowing that
things will go wrong,
but that you can work through
it and things will often
resolve themselves.
Certainly for one experiment
we were working on,
for the Spring Break
onion experiment,
the numbers weren't working out.
And after about
30 hours of work,
I finally found this
one trivial error
I had made at the beginning.
And everything
started working out.
And it was just
putting in the hours
and knowing there's
something there.
You just have to keep
persisting through it.
And it's not an easy
thing to learn to do,
but it's very important.